Among the pantheon of corporations that have
emerged out of Silicon Valley, Uber occupies
a special place.
The company is worth a hundred billion dollars.
Hundreds of billions of dollars worth of trips
and delivery orders have been booked using
its app.
It gets tens of billions of dollars in revenue
each year.
Uber is EVERYWHERE.
And the NARRATIVE of Uber is also everywhere.
It says that Uber is “innovative,” that
it can “disrupt” the taxi industry and
make money doing it.
And it says that it can offer “flexibility”
and “opportunity” to its army of drivers.
Everybody wins.
There’s one problem: NONE OF THAT is true.
Let’s start with one basic fact.
For a company so prominent, there’s something
very strange: Uber has NEVER – not once
– turned a single profit.
You might be confused.
How can it be that such a large company, with
such a popular service, has simply NEVER made
money?
When you find out the answer, you discover
something important.
You discover that Uber is fundamentally a
SCAM – a company that exists to scam its
investors, its users, and, most importantly,
to scam its workers.
Despite everything you might hear, Uber is
NOT a technology company.
While the company may brag about its sophisticated
algorithm, in reality Uber is JUST ANOTHER
TAXI COMPANY.
There is nothing fundamentally more efficient
about Uber than there was with your local
taxi service.
The business is the same: there’s no real
way to “innovate” someone driving someone
or something from Point A to Point B. Using
an app to match riders with drivers is so
simple that local taxi companies DO THE SAME
THING.
In fact, Uber is LESS efficient than taxi
companies.
Most normal taxi companies don’t spend huge
amounts on marketing, or lobbying, or corporate
headquarters; they don’t pay their CEO 45
million dollars a year.
Uber has higher costs than traditional taxi
operators in EVERY category except fuel.
So why is Uber everywhere, while taxi companies
go out of business?
It all goes back to Uber’s master plan.
First: with massive amounts of money from
venture capitalists, Uber subsidized significantly
cheaper rides than what taxi companies could
offer, to attract customers away from them.
Then, after years of undercutting competitors
and driving them to bankruptcy – resulting
in a wave of suicides by cab drivers – Uber
established near-monopolies in local markets.
Now, Uber is often the default way to get
around if you don’t have a car.
And once Uber has eradicated its competition,
it can MAKE ITSELF profitable, at the expense
of users and drivers – raising its fares
to what taxis offered or higher, while pushing
down drivers’ wages.
The plan isn’t efficiency: it’s monopoly.
And that’s not just me theorizing.
A 73-page article in the Transportation Law
Journal took a DEEP LOOK at Uber’s business,
and concluded one thing:
“Uber has NO ABILITY – now or in the foreseeable
future – to earn sustainable profits in
a competitive marketplace.
Uber’s investors cannot earn returns on
the money they have invested without achieving
levels of market dominance that would allow
them to exploit anti-competitive market power.”
So THAT is Uber’s grand plan.
It is not increasing the productivity or efficiency
of the industry that it’s in.
It’s subsidizing its rides with venture
capital cash until it can build a monopoly
and do whatever it wants.
So users who buy Uber’s narrative may be
getting scammed.
But NO ONE is getting it worse than Uber’s
workers.
Uber relies on classifying drivers as “independent
contractors.”
In the United States, that means an individual
provides services to a company, but is independent
of the company and its control.
Uber says that because drivers can choose
what work to accept and for how long, they’re
fully independent.
Now, most of Uber’s workers drive part-time.
But they actually do relatively little driving.
And 90 percent of them quit each year.
The MAJORITY of Uber’s labor is done by
a smaller group of workers, who drive full-time
for the company.
So who are these drivers?
In cities like New York, the vast majority
are immigrants, from places like India, Bangladesh,
and Haiti.
They desperately need cash to support their
families and send remittances back home.
These are people at the VERY MARGINS of our
society.
And how does Uber treat them?
Uber treats them like a pool of cheap labor,
easy to exploit and then discard.
Uber has always been clear about one thing.
IT DOES NOT CARE about its drivers.
At Uber’s greenlight centers, where drivers
register with the company, they were not even
allowed to enter the bathroom RESERVED for
“employees.”
In fact, when Uber was talking about how it
would become profitable, it stated clearly
that it wanted to GET RID of its drivers and
transition entirely to self-driving cars.
But Uber’s technology was so bad that after
burning billions of dollars, it had to give
up.
So for now, Uber is stuck with its drivers.
And in order to appear like it’s coming
closer to profitability, it’s been cutting
their wages since 2015.
Whenever Uber increases its cut from each
trip or reduces the minimum rate for drivers,
its margins improve by that much immediately.
As a result, Uber drivers regularly earn LESS
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE in the places in which
they’re driving.
After taking hidden costs like fuel into account,
the average Uber driver earns a little over
NINE DOLLARS AN HOUR – about 50 percent
LESS than what taxi drivers made before Uber.
In fact, half of Uber drivers live at or below
the federal poverty line.
20 percent of them have to use FOOD STAMPS
to survive.
Unable to afford a home, some drivers even
SLEEP IN THEIR CARS.
Drivers, with nothing to their name, get trapped
in predatory car rental schemes PROMOTED by
Uber – they garnish your wages until you’ve
paid it off with interest.
One study from Georgetown found that a third
of drivers reported falling into a “debt
trap.”
Some ended up earning less than five dollars
an hour.
And because its drivers are technically “independent
contractors,” Uber can avoid pesky requirements
like minimum wages, health insurance, or paid
sick leave.
Drivers can’t unionize to bargain for better
conditions.
Uber has ALL the power, and it makes sure
it can stay that way.
When California tried to classify drivers
as “employees,” Uber spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on a campaign to overturn
it with a ballot proposition WRITTEN BY UBER’S
LAWYERS.
And even though Uber talks about “flexibility,”
that’s not what drivers actually experience.
Drivers may not have physical bosses to order
them around, but they’re ruled by something
even worse – an algorithmic overseer that’s
more intrusive than any flesh-and-blood boss
could ever be.
Uber’s only actual innovations are in surveilling
and disciplining its workforce.
They’re always watching: monitoring driving
behavior, calculating fraud profiles, using
invisible, secret functions to discipline
drivers as well as customers.
Fall below an arbitrary threshold for ratings?
FIRED.
Reject too many trips because you don’t
want to lose any money?
FIRED.
Did a customer make a false report?
So that’s the “freedom” that Uber offers.
It frees drivers to make below minimum wage,
to sleep in their cars, to beg for five-star
ratings and work themselves to the bone.
But at the end of the day, Uber, like other
“gig” companies, IS an innovator.
Not in technology, but in exploitation.
It’s leading the war against labor in ways
other companies never thought possible.
It oversees a pool of ATOMIZED, ULTRA-EXPLOITED
laborers, writes its own regulations, and
has done it all without earning a single cent
of profit.
Imagine what sort of world they’ll need
to start making one.
This is Edward Ongweso, Jr., staff writer
at VICE, for the Gravel Institute.